you likely don't even to tell you how
important it is to understand body
language both to be able to detect it in
others and to be able to use it
ourselves through the use of body
language we can become better
communicators we can engage we can
entertain we can persuade we can explain
we can sell we can lie we can detect
lies we can become more charismatic and
there's never been a time where these
things have been more useful than they
are right now however there's always a
danger that this video would become a
long list of different gestures and
explanations cross downs means X cross
legs means why I didn't want to become
that it's largely useless what you need
to remember is that body language is
very dependent on context individual
differences cultural differences and
it's not enough to just look for one
aspect of body language and then to draw
conclusions you need to look for
clusters of tells you need to consider
the board of context and what you know
about that person and that's why in this
video I want to look more into the
underlying explanation as to what causes
us to communicate where we do with our
bodies and by understanding this
hopefully you'll then be better able to
draw your own conclusions to understand
the bigger picture rather than focusing
on those granular details which may be
misleading so instead of telling you
that rubbing the hands together means
that you're anticipating something I
instead want you to understand why
people were up their hands together in
the first place hopefully that makes
this video a little bit different from
all the other body language videos out
there
first then where does body language come
from why do we gesture and grimace and
lurch when we're trying to employ our
best poker faces there are actually many
reasons and during my own research I
found it helpful to categorize these
into several groups there is some
crossover and it's far from a perfect
system but it might help you to these
categories are communication conscious
embodied cognition / unconscious
communication physiological vestigial /
preparatory and learned so the first
reason we use body language is to
communicate consciously we intentionally
employ the use of gestures stances and
facial expressions when we're trying to
make a point or express ourselves you
might choose to point for emphasis or
you might choose to pull a silly face to
imply humor
the second embodied cognition refers to
a psychological theory seeking to
explain the nature of thought I've made
videos and posts on this in the past but
essentially it's believed that we
understand language and all concepts
ultimately by visualizing them and
relating them to experiences we're
familiar with if I tell you I'm cold you
recall what coldness feels like through
faint firings in your brain and this way
I've shared some of my experience with
you likewise when talking we visualize
in order to explain and describe what we
mean to others we might therefore also
gesture or pull expressions to literally
paint the picture and convey meaning in
an unconscious manner this also extends
to the use of additional language that
isn't planned the choice of certain
adjectives for instance body language
arising from physiological factors
refers to visible changes in the body
that result from the production of
certain neurotransmitters that might
mean shaking from adrenaline for
instance or flushing red when blood
rushes to the face this type of body
language is perhaps the hardest to fake
learned body language is closely related
to both communicative and embodied
cognition these are gestures that have
been learned over time and may be
cultural or functional for instance the
first time a baby reaches for something
and a parent hands it to them they learn
that they congested towards things that
they want
similarly we learn to smile at people as
we pass we might learn him to bow when
meeting our superiors depending on our
cultural background etc
finally vestigial or preparatory are
those body language traits that would
have served a purpose during our
evolution and have since stuck around
for example we furrow our bro when angry
to protect our eyes in a fight and we
might point our feet towards an exit in
preparation to run we wouldn't engage in
those behaviors in a modern situation
but the survival impulse is too strong
again this is hard to fake so what can
you do with all this information the aim
is to look out for situations where one
or more of these aspects of body
language provide useful information
without jumping to conclusions in
particular when looking for signs that
someone is concealing their true
feelings we should try to identify in
multiple aspects of their body language
that can service tells the more signs we
can spot the surer we can be of our
conclusions so for example let's look at
uncomfortable social situations let's
say someone is uncomfortable in a
situation or wants to leave a
conversation one thing we might look for
is a foot pointing towards an exit this
is a vestigial behavior in preparation
for running or leaving in fact according
to Joe Navarro X FBI agent and author of
what everybody is saying the feet are
the most honest part of the body the
reason for this is the preparing to run
as such strong survival value that it's
very difficult to override not only that
but where as we have learned to disguise
our expressions many of us forget to
consider what we're doing with our feet
especially as they're often concealed
under a table but of course it may just
be that that person is comfortable in
the position they're in their feature so
happened to be pointed towards an exit
therefore we also need to look for other
potential signs that a person's not
comfortable in that current conversation
before we can draw a conclusion to this
end we might look for the absence of ICO
cracks ISM body language mirroring
normally when we're establishing a good
rapport with someone we will
unconsciously adopt their same
positioning if they should lean forwards
for example then often we will do too
this is both a vestigial behavior as it
would have helped improve social
interactions for our ancestors as well
as an embodied cognitive one as we can
better understand the thoughts of
someone else by adopting the same
position and expressions if someone is
not comfortable in a social setting
they won't exhibit this behavior in fact
they might struggle to maintain eye
contact with that person as they're
effectively trying to block them out so
by looking for all these different signs
together we can then will confidently
make the conclusion that that person is
not
comfortable in that conversation
likewise if someone stands very close to
another person invading their personal
space
this is often a sign that they intend to
follow up with an act of aggression
this is proxemics but while this is true
a lot of the time we once again must
keep in mind context and other signs did
you know for example that according to
the book body language how to read
others thoughts by their gestures by
Allen Pease our sense of personal space
is dictated by both culture and up
wringing more specifically those of us
who grew up in densely populated spaces
are used to standing closer to others
than those of us from rural backgrounds
which makes sense when you think about
it likewise we might get closer to
someone if we're feeling intimate so we
shouldn't instantly assume closeness
means an upcoming altercation so other
signs to look out for in this instance
might include a widening of the stance
this preparatory movement spreads the
center of gravity and readies us for
action you'd never see some cross their
legs and mess they were very relaxed
with crossed legs you're not ready to
move and if you're pushed you're gonna
fall over likewise we might expect to
see physiological changes the nostrils
flare as the individual takes in more
oxygen then knuckles might tense and the
heart rate might increase leading to
subtle reddening of the skin
now you can fairly safely presume that a
fight is about to break out and you can
take the relevant action so those are
just some examples of how you might use
an understanding of body language to
read the person's intentions or beliefs
hopefully by understanding the root
cause of these gestures and movements
you'll become better at drawing your own
conclusions without the need for a huge
long list of different gestures but most
people will read this and then forget
all about it
understanding body language and reading
body language are two very different
things most of us myself definitely
included simply aren't observant enough
to remember to do it that's why if
you're serious about learning to read
people you need to actively practice it
think of it like a workout like any
other workout you'll take a slot of time
every day a week and use it to actively
watch for body language if you commute
to work for instance or go to coffee
shops often and these are perfect
opportunities to practice your skills
try to read the subtext in conversations
you see around you just take a few
minutes at a time and eventually it'll
start to become second nature another
tip is to start very basic one really
easy question to ask in any situation to
begin with is is this person comfortable
the fight-or-flight response is one of
the most difficult psychological
responses to disguise and it makes
itself known in the host of interesting
ways
finally keep in mind that we do have a
kind of innate ability to read body
language you pick up on a lot of these
tales unconsciously so if you get an
uneasy feeling that someone isn't being
entirely truthful maybe go with it and
this is also why I haven't delved into
micro expressions or osteo six eye
movements seeing as it would be pretty
much useless in a practical setting
though I might cover these things in
detail in future over at the website
finally as well as reading body language
there's also great merit in learning to
control your own body language and
thereby to better express yourself and
manage the impressions that you make if
you want to appear more confident then
adopting relaxed poses taking up more
physical space using haptics that means
touching people for instance on the
shoulder and avoiding pacifying
behaviors or nervous tics
will do the trick if you want to get
someone to like you subtly mirroring
their body language can also go a long
way and make you more persuasive and if
you want to come across as more
charismatic and engaging then you should
use larger gesticulations and really
embody the story you're trying to convey
pause for dramatic effect and use visual
storytelling gesticulations make us seem
more engaging because we look like we
really believe in what we're saying
which makes us seem genuine and makes
the message seem more important at the
same time it's also easier to follow us
and to really picture the narrative
being conveyed the problem though is
that trying to force these things will
very often come across as fake or
unsettling and can ultimately have the
opposite effect to that which is
intended you might be able to control
what you're saying to handle your
gestures and to avoid your nervous
habits but it might be much harder to
control your physiological response and
if you're shaking or flushing then that
can give the game away the answer might
be to take genuine control over your own
cognitive and physiological processes in
other words we appear calm and confident
by controlling our breathing and
training ourselves to thrive in
stressful situations and we appear more
charismatic
by genuinely enjoying the company we're
in and really believing in what we're
saying and if you don't know how to
achieve those things then there are a
few things you can do meditation might
help practice definitely helps acting
lessons or stand-up comedy can help and
cognitive behavioral therapy is very
useful so thanks a ton for watching guys
I hope transferred a useful interesting
if you did then please leave a like down
below please comment and share it around
all those things helped me out immensely
let me know if I've missed any cool
tricks or tells that you use when you're
reading or using body language I've got
lots more cool stuff on the way I am
getting to the night wing training video
very soon I'm gonna be looking at how to
jump higher gonna be looking at how to
increase your work capacity I've got
some more cool legends that were going
to learn from you can vote on who I
cover next
over at the patreon but currently da
Vinci Dwayne the rock Johnson and a
couple of others are doing quite well in
that vote I'm gonna be looking at
Shaolin training who the most effective
warrior cultures were and I've got a
video coming very soon on my youtube
business and how to earn money through
YouTube so if that all sounds cool
then thanks a ton for watching and I'll
see you next time bye for now I want to
explain why we rub our hands together
like I mentioned at the beginning the
reason is likely because we interact
with things physically using our hands
and we certainly always did back when we
were in the wild
therefore you rub your hands in
anticipation because well basically
you're priming the things you're going
to use to grab that thing